y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
realmente
cuidamos lo que nos identifica
y esto que les voy a contar
es algo que aprendí de mis hijas
soy alejandra soy arquitecta no soy de
concordia pero la ciudad que elegí para
vivir para trabajar
ya te dije soy take that he tenido la
suerte de poder pasar más de la mitad de
mi vida
haciendo lo que me apasiona que es
cuidar y crear los espacios que la gente
pero también investigó
trabajo estudios sobre el patrimonio
patrimonio construido aquellos lugares
del pasado que deben ser cuidados para
que no desaparezcan
hace algunos años tuve la oportunidad de
participar a través de un concurso de de
la consolidación y puesta en valor de
castillos arcanos
tal vez no será demasiado pretencioso de
castillo
si pensamos en los castillos europeos
el foso no tiene los elementos típicos
de un platillo
si se puede parecer
en cuanto a la construcción y poder
construcción de piedra y de ladrillos y
también a los materiales que se
utilizaron para la construcción la
mayoría de entrada
los siervos de inglaterra
los revestimientos de alemania- los
árboles en carrara
las lámparas mobiliarios en terciopelo
de francés de lugar lo que se utilizó
fue la piedra arenisca que se obtenía
del río
es una construcción importante
las iniciales de su propietario así como
el año de construcción de finales del
siglo 19 se encuentran en el portón de
acceso
la vivienda es una vivienda
importante que tiene dos plantas una
planta alta donde están las habitaciones
principales de la vivienda y una planta
baja o semienterrada donde se encuentran
las habitaciones de servicio y la
caballería
pero también de importancia
radicaba en el aspecto comercial y esta
casa fue edificada en un lugar a orillas
del río uruguay donde había un saladero
una fábrica de conservas
se instaló la primera fábrica de hielos
de la argentina hay en esta red y
artística es decir se iba a ser un lugar
un nuevo comercial y productivo
se encuentra en una ubicación
privilegiada
la casa fue edificada en una de las más
altas de concordia con una vegetación
frondosa conservan galerías y orillas
del río uruguay con vistas al salto
chico
pero en definitiva
sueño palacio ni es un castillo es una
hermosa casa con la piel con lorca de
amigo
pero hagamos un poco de historia
esta casa como ya le dije fue construida
a finales del siglo 19 por igual demás
una industrial francés que le decían
conde aunque récord de estrategia na
la casa bueno pues ya dijimos destinada
a
un lugar además de vivienda un lugar
importante para la producción
la vida de los demás y en este lugar fue
apenas desaparición criteriosamente por
mucho tiempo
eso comenzó a tejer algunas fantasías y
leyendas en el guardia luego la casa
pasó por varias instancias fue
abandonada fue dada fue vendida hasta
que finalmente la adquiere la
municipalidad de concordia y la esquila
nuevamente la esquila a la familia food
balón que fue una familia muy importante
para la historia de este lugar en una
familia francesa conjuntos algo
extravagante criaban animales salvajes
son los más postas serpientes iguanas
un día las niñas de la familia ven a
aterrizar un avión en un campo lindero a
la casa
era nada más ni nada menos que antes en
el súper
el en ese momento del piloto comercial
había tenido una avería en el avión y
tuvo que entrenarse en concón quedó
encantado del lugar volvió en varias
oportunidades
y se hizo amigo de la familia
ya en francia escribió acerca de ella y
su sal como las princesitas argel
también en tierra de hombres
escribe en el capítulo oasis acerca de
concordia es una descripción de la casa
y del lugar
y por supuesto es el autor del éxito uno
de los libros más importantes del mundo
que fueron inspirado en estos lugares
la casa nuevamente pasado un tiempo que
daba buenas
fue saqueada comienza su deterioro va
perdiendo lo que quedaba de esa
movilidad por ti
los mármoles
hasta hicieron árboles adentro de las
habitaciones
y hasta que un voraz incendio en el año
termino con lo que quedaba del lector de
esa casa
y se transforma
pasaron 60 años
se decidiera el destino de esta pasta
a través de una consulta popular que
realizó realizó la música
era tan amada esta casa por los
concordienses que no querían
desprenderse de ella
que tenía esa casa para que hicieran
conservaban tal y como estaba hasta ese
momento
porque una intervención arquitectónica
tiene que ser puesta a votación para
poder realizarse esas eran algunas de
las preguntas que yo me hacía a medida
que me iba acercando aproximando a la
casa
y conociendo a la
pasaron algunos alguien más y se comenzó
con las tareas de puesta en valor
de de castillos al cabo
esto se transformó en una de las
experiencias más motivadoras de carrera
profesional
se organizó un equipo de arquitectos de
hielo
y así otros
y obreros comenzó una rutina sin
demasiado sol y sal
comenzaron las obras se comenzó hasta la
limpieza del lugar el primer lugar una
de las quejas más comunes
y escuchar a los salvajes que se
quejaban porque tenían piedra piedra
ladrillo ladrillo el palacio del rey
pero hasta acá veníamos trabajando sin
demasiados cambios hasta que comenzaron
a suceder algunos hechos que les voy a
les voy a contar
bueno como toda obra se comienza
haciendo un obrador
ha hablado de
al lado del edificio principal
por ahí comentaba que se escuchaban
pasos de hojas
voces sordos
no escuchan una voz de mujer y del otro
lado y begoña
acaba de llegar
una vez
visitó un señor que había vivido siempre
en el lugar cuando era niño jugaba en
ese lugar siempre en la zona del parque
y él nos aseguraba que en las
caballerizas había tuna
nos señalaba jugar nos decía que cuando
con sus amigos quería entrar en una vela
porque nos were muy oscuro
se apaga
nosotros nunca pudimos contactar
efectivamente hubiera poner en el pasaje
lugar de
de castillo
otra cosa que pasaba bastante
frecuentemente
los que tenían que hacer el cuidado a la
noche del lugar
preferían hacerlo de sábado de afuera
cual dentro del lado
un grupo que no sólo había habitantes
yo no encontraba demasiada explicación a
todo esto yo escuchaba cada uno
manifestaba sus experiencias
y quizás podían tener que ver con la
partida abrupta de más y todas esas
galletas que se fueron creciendo
alrededor
algún día
cuando estábamos limpiando las
caballerizas es actualmente el centro de
interpretación un lugar que estaba
repleto de murciélagos aparecer en un
rinconcito de la bovedilla de hecho
una carta de agua
si ustedes me preguntan qué fue
lo que hizo en mí que yo cambiara mi
forma de mirar y de acercarme
al hueso
y casi adoptando como propio yo no sé
tiene que ver seguramente con toda esa
fantasía con toda la magia del lugar y
saco lo que yo
pero alguien
entendí los secretos que guardan las
paredes
entre ti porque la gente hizo cuidar y
proteger la reina de castilla acercarlo
con una consulta popular
entendidas tiendas
y lo que quiero alcalde es un ex de este
nexo feliz para escribir
pero más allá de todo eso yo los invito
a pensar
cuando ustedes tengan la oportunidad de
conocer cualquiera en cualquier lugar
no se queden solamente con lo construido
porque un edificio es mucho más es
historias ahí vivió gente
pasaron cosas los edificios tienen más
que una historia para no dudarlo
por eso yo los invito a que aprendamos
a ver con el corazón
porque lo esencial es incidentes
ya